- So Matt Gaetz.
(upbeat music)
Sponsored by Ting Mobile
Hey LegalEagles It's time to think
like a very busy criminal defense lawyer
because what is going on
with the Matt Gaetz scandal.
And I'm afraid we're gonna
have to be more specific
than that because it appears
that there is a scandal
inside of a scandal inside of a scandal.
It's like one of those
Russian nesting dolls
but it's all Florida men all the way down.
But the question is,
did any of Matt Gaetz's alleged
relationships break the law?
Are the wild stories about Matt Gaetz
and his father just a pack
of lies dreamed up by two men
who were trying to
blackmail the Gaetz family
or does it hold some truth?
So let's go through the
timeline of allegations
against congressman Gaetz
and see if any of these allegations
might give rise to illegal conduct.
And let me stress that at this point
these allegations are all unproven.
He denies everything and there
are conflicting accounts.
But one thing is certain
that if you thought
that weird political
scandals were gonna end
with the Trump administration,
you haven't been paying
attention to Florida Man.
So let's start at the beginning.
In late March political news
sites reported that Gaetz
was thinking about not
running for reelection
and becoming a talking head
on the news organization, Newsmax.
Some reported that he was even thinking
about ending his term early
so that he could join the private sector.
But this left a lot of
people scratching their heads
about why a young congressman
would consider Newsmax a promotion.
Well, as we would soon learn,
the department of justice was
apparently investigating Gaetz
for federal crimes.
And here's some free #notlegaladvice.
Working for cable TV
does not give you any
immunity from prosecution.
But not long after the
New York Times reported
that the DOJ was investigating Gaetz
for possibly having had
a sexual relationship
with a 17 year old and paying
her to travel with him.
Not surprisingly several
federal statutes make it illegal
to induce someone under the age of 18
to travel over state lines,
to engage in sex in exchange for money,
or something of value.
The main federal law is 8 U.S.C. 1591
which prohibits sex trafficking
of children by force fraud or coercion.
And for purposes of this law,
a minor is someone under
the age of 18 years old.
This statute also makes
it a federal offense
to knowingly recruit,
entice, harbor, transport,
provide, obtain, or
maintain a minor knowing
or in reckless disregard
of the fact that the victim is a minor
and would be caused to engage
in a commercial sex act.
And that is defined exactly
the way you would think it was.
Now section 1591 does not
require proof that either
the defendant or victim
crossed state lines
or international lines.
The prosecuting officer
doesn't need to prove
the defendant used force threats
of force fraud or coercion.
But if the victim was
between 14 and 17 years old
the penalty is a minimum sentence
of 10 years in prison up to life.
Now, Gaetz has denied the charges
and told the New York Times,
"I have a suspicion that someone is trying
to recategorize my
generosity to ex-girlfriends
as something more untoward"
which sort of raises the question,
how do you mischaracterize
generosity toward someone
who is not a minor in this context?
But that is a question for another time.
And here there are reports
that the alleged 17 year
old victim was also involved
in a felony sex trafficking
count against Joel Greenberg.
Greenberg is a former Seminole
County, Florida tax collector
who has been charged with 33
counts from four indictments,
including sex trafficking with a minor
whom Gaetz was allegedly involved with.
Now, Greenberg is also one
of Gaetz's Florida pals.
Here they are goofing around
with known upstanding citizen
Roger Stone, and here they
are at the white house.
Now Greenberg became the
youngest tax collector
in the county's history
and allegedly has spent over
$1 million on guns, body armor,
and his own cryptocurrency scheme,
and a drone while in office.
And in 2017, Greenberg pulled over a woman
he thought was speeding to scold her,
while he wore his tax collector's badge
that resembled a sheriff's badge.
And for some reason he even
had flashing police lights
on the top of his SUV.
Now, amazingly the Florida
state attorney wrote in a letter
the Greenberg was, "Being
given the benefit of the doubt
that his intentions were pure."
Therefore he did not commit the crime
of impersonating a police officer.
And look, I've been to Florida,
so that does seem to check out
but that probably wouldn't
fly in any other context
in any other state,
but in 2018 Gaetz publicly
endorsed Greenberg's bid
for reelection saying that,
one day Greenberg would make
a fine member of Congress.
We'll pause to let that one sink in
but Greenberg was then
charged with stalking
and harassing a teacher
who was running against him
in the Republican primary.
Greenberg had apparently
set up fake online profiles
to defame the teacher
and sent several letters
to the school where he worked saying that
the man engaged in inappropriate
conduct with his students.
In July of 2019 Gaetz and Greenberg
left obnoxious voicemails
on the cell phone
of Florida state
representative, Anna Eskamani,
a Democrat saying.
- [Greeberg] This is your
favorite tax collector,
I'm up in the panhandle
with your favorite US
Congressmen Mr. Gaetz.
- [Gaetz] Hi Anna.
- Then in August of 2020,
Greenberg was indicted on 14 more counts,
including sex trafficking
charges related to a minor
between the ages of 14 and 17.
Now, unfortunately,
the details of Greenberg's
alleged trafficking scheme
are also essential to understanding
why Gaetz is in hot water.
First federal prosecutors,
alleged that Greenberg used his position
as tax collector to
access the Florida driver
and vehicle information database
where he would research women and girls.
Some of the individuals Greenberg research
were involved in sugar daddy
relationships with Greenberg.
And Greenberg allegedly
abused his position
and took surrendered driver's licenses
before they were shredded
by his office staff,
and created new ideas with his photograph
but with the personal
information of his residents.
And not surprisingly during a search,
police found fake IDs
in Greenberg's office
and materials used to
create those IDs as well.
Greenberg of course denies
all of these allegations,
which takes us back to congressman Gaetz.
Gaetz allegedly visited
the Seminole County tax
collector's office at least twice
after hours according to
text messages reviewed
by the Orlando Sentinel
and the Daily Beast.
And on April 16, 2018 Greenberg visited
the Lake Mary Florida branch
of his tax collection agency.
Surveillance footage captured
Greenberg standing near a desk
with another man,
but Greenberg forgot to set
the alarm on the way out
which concerned the
assistant branch manager
when she went to work on Monday morning.
That employee found driver's licenses
scattered all over the desk
instead of in the
appropriate disposal basket.
She reviewed the camera
footage and alerted her boss
who sent Greenberg a text message saying,
"Did you happen to visit
the Lake Mary Office
on the weekend?"
The Daily Beast reports,
the Greenberg responded.
Yes, I was showing Congressman Gaetz
what our operation looked like.
Did I leave something on?
And according to the Daily
Beast text messages saw that,
Greenberg was helping Gaetz
get some duplicate IDs.
They reported that,
on September 2nd, 2018 Greenberg
directly asked an employee
to quickly create a new card that complies
with the heightened security
standards of real ID,
a process that would
normally require providing
additional documentation
according to the images.
The Daily Beast goes on to report
that Greenberg texted
one of his employees,
"Amy- is there anyway to
assist one of our congressmen
in getting an emergency replacement ID,
or DL by Tuesday 2:00 PM.
His was lost yesterday
and he's got a flight Tuesday.
Doesn't have any other form
of ID currently on him.
Sorry to bother you on Sunday.
Greenberg then confirmed
that the favor was for,
"Matthew Louis Gaetz
Jr. Born May 7th, 1982."
If you didn't know, Gaetz
represents Northwest Florida
while Greenberg was tax
collector in Seminole County,
which is 472 miles away
from Gaetz's district.
So why did Gaetz need the tax collector
from outside his district
to create IDs for him?
These are of course red flags.
So when the secret service
was apparently investigating
Greenberg for identity theft,
they discovered the link to Gaetz.
And shortly before the
story about Gaetz broke,
Greenberg was indicted yet again,
this time for allegedly
submitting false claims
to receive pandemic relief
aid from the government,
and trying to bribe a government official.
Yes, Greenberg allegedly did all of this
after his other illegal troubles.
And reports say that the
independent Gaetz investigation
was launched under the
Trump administration,
and that attorney general Bill Barr
was briefed on the matter,
and actively trying to avoid
meeting Gaetz in person,
because of potential improprieties
given the ongoing investigation.
And there is yet more evidence
that the Gaetz Greenberg investigation
involves other Florida officials.
A woman told investigators
that she had had sex
with Greenberg, Gaetz,
and another guy involved
in Florida, GOP politics.
Several sources told reporters
from Floridapolitics.com
that the third man is former
Florida Department of Business
and Professional Regulation
secretary, Halsey Beshears
who resigned in January.
The woman allegedly was a minor
at the time of the sexual encounter.
And several reporters say
that she has already testified
in front of a grand jury,
about having had sex with Matt Gaetz.
And according to another
unnamed, Florida Republican,
who claims to be influential
in state politics,
Greenberg texted him on August 14th,
and started fuming
about the investigation.
The source claims that Greenberg
was paying the legal fees
for the woman who allegedly
slept with Gaetz and Greenberg,
"Greenberg initially referred
to the young woman as vintage 99"
referring to the year she was born 1999,
protip putting inculpatory
evidence in digital form
especially when you're talking about
the birth date of a minor,
really not the best way
to criminal activity.
According to reports, Greenberg wrote,
I'm having to pay for vintage
99 to retain a lawyer.
They, the federal agents contacted her,
and are wanting to her to talk.
She doesn't want to talk to them.
Now paying for someone's legal fees
is not necessarily illegal,
but it does raise a
whole host of questions.
The woman in question is now allegedly 20,
but was allegedly 17 at
the time of the encounter.
And the friend said that Greenberg
and Gaetz shared girlfriends
and paid their bills.
And after the investigation
started Greenberg
apparently reached out
to his friends stating,
"I'm trying to let everyone
know who came into contact
with any of these girls.
The feds are going
through my Venmo history
and don't want anyone
to be caught off guard."
To which one of Greenberg's
friends responded promptly
by saying that, he wasn't on Venmo
and had no such history
with any of these women and,
"Absolutely positively leave
my name out of any of this.
I'm serious about this Joel."
And meanwhile the third man
in the White House photo op
with Greenberg and Gaetz
has been identified.
His name is Chris Dorworth,
a former member of the Florida legislature
who was close with Gaetz.
Dorworth quit his job
with a lobbying firm late last week.
And his presence has now been scrubbed
from the firm's website.
Dorworth and Gaetz allegedly plotted
to run a sham third-party candidate
during a state senate race
to help out Jason Brodeur.
Another friend of Gaetz,
the two men said they probably
didn't discuss running
a sham candidate and Dorworth added.
There would be nothing
illegal about it if we had.
Greenburg may also have some dirt
on other Florida politicians as well.
He allegedly use taxpayer money to pay
for other Florida politicians,
and WWE wrestler Matt
Morgan known as Blueprint
for quote consulting services.
Auditors have yet to
find the documentation
for what these payments were actually for,
Morgan happened to owe about
$40,000 in federal taxes.
And the consulting payments happened
to be for about $40,000.
Florida voters later elected Blueprint
to the Longwood City Commission,
because of course they did,
this is Florida after all.
And back to Greenberg sources
told the New York Times
that Greenberg would find
women on sugar daddy websites,
forums that would connect
people who would go on dates
in exchange for gifts, find
dining, travel, and allowances,
and presumably have sex with them.
He would then allegedly
introduce these women
to Gaetz who would also have sex with him.
And the reports say that
the men would meet women
to form mutually beneficial relationships
between the two parties.
But this probably goes without saying,
but in America you cannot pay for sex
without breaking the law.
So let's talk about the
crime of solicitation.
The New York Times originally
reported that Greenberg
and Gaetz had paid women
for sex using Cash App,
and Apple Pay stating,
"The times has reviewed
receipts from Cash App,
mobile payments app, and Apple Pay
that show payments from
Mr. Gaetz and Mr. Greenberg
to one of the women,
and a payment from Mr.
Greenberg to a second woman,
the woman told her friends
the payments were for sex with the two men
according to two people,
familiar with the conversations
and encounters during
2019 and 2020 Mr. Gaetz
and Mr. Greenberg instructed the women
to meet at certain times,
and places often at hotels around Florida
and would tell them the amount of money
they were willing to pay,
according to the messages and interviews.
And additionally, the Daily Beast reports
they obtained records.
The two men also used Venmo
to pay the women for sex.
Again, allegedly two of the transactions
are from may of 2018.
When Gaetz sent Greenberg $900.
The first transaction
from Gaetz says, "Test."
The second page Greenberg $900.
But the memo reading, hit up, blank,
using a nickname for one of the girls.
Six hours later, Greenberg
paid three young women $900,
in the memo line for
payments Greenberg wrote,
tuition school and school.
One of the girls had just turned 18
about six months before the transaction.
So the report does not name her.
And according to the Daily Beast,
Gaetz has Venmo transactions
were once public
but they disappeared this week.
As the investigation moves forward.
Just a reminder,
you may wanna set all of your
Venmo transactions to private
whether you're doing
something illegal or not,
#notlegaladvice.
The Daily Beast was also able to confirm
that the circles of contact
between Gaetz and Greenberg
overlap using Venmo records,
Instagram and campaign finance records,
"Gaetz and Greenberg's share
two direct Venmo connections
with women who received
payments from Greenberg.
Greenberg is also accused
of misusing taxpayer funds
but at least $300,000 allegedly being used
for hotels, travel meals, consulting,
and even cash advances on
a county's credit card.
Which takes us to the possible crime
of enticement of a minor.
If Greenburg and Gaetz
had contact with minors
using technology like
these sugar daddy websites
or text messages or payment
apps, if that's true
they could be charged with
violating 18 U.S.C. 2422
which makes it a crime to use the US mail
or certain technologies such
as the internet, telephone,
to persuade, induce,
entice or coerce a minor,
to engage in prostitution
or any other illegal sexual activity.
And it's possible that these
alleged acts might give rise
to a violation of the Mann Act as well.
But there's also the international
travel aspect of this
federal investigators are also
looking into a Bahamas trip
that Gaetz allegedly took in late 2018,
or early 2019 with a
marijuana entrepreneur.
The marijuana guy allegedly paid
for the travel accommodations
and female escorts.
But even if the other guy was responsible
that wouldn't necessarily
get Gaetz off the hook
because 18 U.S.C. 2423
makes it a felony to,
"knowingly transporting an individual
who has not attained the age of 18 years
in interstate or foreign
commerce with the intent that
the individual engaged in prostitution
or any sexual activity
for which a person can be
charged with a criminal offense.
This law targets human
trafficking of underage people.
The minimum penalty for
this offense is 10 years
and the maximum is life.
And additionally, the
New York Times reports
that Gaetz was allegedly using drugs,
"some of the men and women took ecstasy
and illegal mood altering drug
before having sex, including Mr. Gaetz,
two people familiar with
the encounters said,
no of course there are the
drug violations themselves.
But if this is true,
Gaetz has legal exposure
under the Trafficking Persons
Protection Act of 2000
which makes it illegal
to course any person,
adult or child into sex acts.
And in the past federal prosecutors
have filed trafficking charges
against people suspected
of providing drugs in exchange for sex
because facilitating
another person's drug habit
can be a form of coercion.
And then there's the issue
of paying for hotel stays
and meals in exchange for
some sort of relationship.
The times reported that
Gaetz had a cover story
for anyone asking about his relationships.
"In some cases, Mr. Gaetz
asked women to help find others
who might be interested
in having sex with him
and his friends,
according to two people familiar
with those conversations.
Should anyone acquire
about their relationships,
one person said,
Mr. Gaetz told the women to say
that he had paid for hotel rooms
and dinners as part of their dates."
And CNN spoke to two women
who claimed to have
attended several parties
with Greenberg and Gaetz.
Some of the parties took place
after GOP political events.
They say that they share
drugs like cocaine and ecstasy
at the parties and witnessed
Matt Gaetz taking pills.
She said that he behaved like
a frat type of party boy.
It probably goes without saying,
but if Gaetz did in
fact use campaign funds
for illegal activities or
even non campaign activities,
that could certainly
give rise to a campaign.
Finance violation
CNN has reviewed receipts
indicating the Greenberg
and Gaetz used digital payment apps
to send hundreds of dollars
to at least one woman at these parties.
One receipt had a label indicating
the payment was for travel.
And one of the women told CNN
that Greenberg sent her money,
after some of these parties,
she confirmed that some of
the money was payment for sex
but she did not disclose
who she slept with.
The woman said that
she did not receive money
directly from Gaetz.
And Greenberg allegedly bragged
about partying with Gaetz
a source close to Greenberg alleges
that he often quote sent
identically worded messages
to multiple women,
inviting them to parties
through these so-called
sugar daddy dating websites.
If this is true, prosecutors
would need evidence proving
that there was some coercion
because generally speaking
it's not to pay for hotels
and dinner or give gifts.
As long as the people
are actually both adults
and along these lines,
Gaetz has defendants has action saying,
"I definitely, in my single days,
provided for women I've dated."
You know, I paid for
flights for hotel rooms,
I've been, you know,
generous as a partner.
I think someone is trying
to make that look criminal when it's not.
And then there is the issue
of the potential nude photos on his phone.
Gaetz allegedly showed
other lawmakers photos
and videos of nude women.
He'd said he'd slept with,
even showing pictures on the house floor.
Now is talking about sexual
relationships, a crime?
No, not necessarily,
but given the context it is possible,
there was some illegality.
First of all, if the photos
or videos are of a minor girl
you can understand exactly
why that would be illegal.
And additionally,
if the photos or videos
were taken without consent,
that could also be a crime.
Washington. DC is one
of the few jurisdictions
with a so-called revenge porn law.
This revenge porn law
criminalizes the dissemination
of sexually explicit photographs of anyone
without his or her consent.
But these revenge porn laws
are not without controversy
because they criminalize
some form of sexting
and are not necessarily pornographic.
And then there also the
first amendment implications
former Democratic representative,
Katie Hill resigned
after her, ex-husband
shared nude photos of her
and a conservative
website in British tabloid
published those pictures.
He'll quit and file the
lawsuit against the tabloid
for violating California's
revenge porn law.
But just this week, a
California court ruled
that the publication was
protected by the first amendment.
And ironically Hill, and Gaetz
formed an unlikely friendship
when she was in Congress.
Now grand jury proceedings
are supposed to remain secret
and we don't know for sure
if one is actually looking at Matt Gaetz,
how are things are certainly looking grim
for the congressmen on that front.
On April 8th Greenberg's
lawyer told the media
that his client was negotiating
a plea deal with prosecutors.
- I'm sure Matt Gaetz,
is not feeling very comfortable today.
- It's certainly a warning shot,
and if you're Matt Gaetz's attorney,
that's not something you wanna
hear from other defendants.
And then perhaps the weirdest twist of all
on the same day that the allegations
against Gaetz became public.
He appeared on Fox news
with Tucker Carlson,
Gaetz denied the allegations
and then things got super weird.
When he said that he was the
victim of an extortion plot.
- What is happening is an
extortion of me and my family,
involving a former department
of justice official.
- Gaetz also use it as an opportunity
to remind Tucker Carlson
at that time that he
had dinner with Gaetz,
and one of his girlfriends.
- You and I went to dinner
about two years ago,
your wife was there and I
brought a friend of mine.
You'll remember her?
- I don't remember the
woman you're speaking of
what were the context at all honestly.
- And then he pointed
out that Carlson knows
what it's like to be falsely
accused of sex crime.
- I'm not the only person
on screen right now
who has been falsely accused
of a terrible sex act.
You were accused of something
that you did not do.
And so, you know what this feels like.
- Which is not a great way to ensure that
you get a friendly
interview in the future,
but you should know that
even if these extortion
allegations are true
it's entirely possible
for Gaetz to be a victim
of extortion while also being investigated
for illegal things that
they actually have done.
Often, the only way to extort someone
is that they engaged in some
sort of illegal conduct.
But at this point we don't know
where the fabrications start and end.
And specifically Gaetz says
the two former government
officials found out
about the investigation
and tried to shake down the Gaetz family.
Gaetz said that his father had
actually been wearing a wire
in order to help the FBI
catch the alleged extorting.
Don Gaetz is a former
Florida Senate president
who was the wealthiest member
of the Florida legislature.
The Gaetz family actually
became extremely wealthy
through the hospice care industry.
And the senior Gaetz has
back to his son's claim.
Of course, the two individuals
accused of blackmailing
the Gaetz family have both
denied these allegations.
Even if someone was trying
to extort Matt Gaetz
and or his family,
the mere fact of the extortion
wouldn't change any of the
criminal guilt associated
with those alleged acts.
So we'll see what happens
with the extortion.
Now, if there's one lesson
that we can take away from any of that
is that if you are potentially
a criminal defendant
you probably shouldn't
put inculpatory evidence
in your Venmo history.
But if you are gonna pay for
illicit activity over at Venmo,
then you'll need a good
cell phone provider.
And the best is Ting Mobile.
I personally switched to T-Mobile why,
well, because of this,
yes, that is a real cell phone bill
that I got with my previous provider.
And it's why I personally
switched to Ting Mobile,
and Ting Mobile has three
brand new plans to make sure
that that never happens to you.
You can get talk in texts
for only $10 a month,
data plan starting at $25 a month,
and unlimited for $45 a month.
Switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number,
and use pretty much any
phone that you want.
And the service is great too
because Ting partners with
several massive networks
probably the very same one
that you're using right now
but you get a huge discount.
Now, actually, I can't tell you which ones
because I always respect contracts
but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all.
Now I've been on the phone
with my previous providers
for hours over the simplest things
or trying to deal with huge bills,
but they always put me on hold.
But with Ting, you can call them up,
and immediately talk
to a real human being.
Or you can talk to them on
Chat, Discord, you name it,
they are available.
And it's incredibly easy
to transfer your service
just by simply ordering
a SIM card popping in
and setting it up.
No phone calls required at all.
It's like magic.
And if you're around WiFi all the time,
and you don't need an unlimited plan,
like you're working from home,
then you have the flexibility
to save hundreds of dollars a year,
because ting still gives you the option
to just pay for what you
use with their flex plan.
It's a smarter, cheaper
version, of the same plan
that they've always had.
And now they just give you the possibility
of unlimited versions as well.
So if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
So if you'd like to try out my
mobile provider Ting Mobile,
just go to LegalEagle.Ting.com.
LegalEagles will get a special $25 credit
that could cover two months of service.
Or you can just click on
the link in the description
and give it a try.
Plus clicking on that
link in the description
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis,
leave your objections in the comments
and please do not put
evidence of illegal activity
in your Venmo history,
but do check out this playlist
with all of my other real law reviews
where I tackle the
legal issues of the day.
So click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.